évoluer dans cet espace naturel avec
pour seul objectif sa préservation
lorenzo saint sauveur est ici dans son
élément depuis une dizaine d'années cet
agent du conseil départemental travaille
à l'entretien la restauration et la
sauvegarde des espaces naturels
sensibles propriété du département
ça fait donc dix ans que je suis donc à
la direction de l'environnement
donc là c'est un petit peu
l'aboutissement d'un parcours donc de
formation donc toujours été attiré par
tout ce qui concerne que le monde des
vivants et là c'était l'occasion qui
était temps de mettre en pratique dans
tout ce que j'ai tout ce que j'ai pu
apprendre au cours de ma formation de
mon parcours scolaire et puis c'est
aussi l'occasion du monde de participer
donc un grand projet qui est donc la
préservation et la protection des
milieux naturels donc de l'île de la
réunion
cent mille hectares d'espacés naturels
constituée en grande partie de forêt
mais aussi d'une grande variété de
milieux et c'est cette richesse de la
matière qui a séduit lorenzo saint
sauveur c'est important de préserver
denquin biodiversité donc parce que tu
es qui montre là on a par exemple sur le
site de domaine fleuri et donc une
particularité de cette année sur un
milieu de zones semi sèche donc
il faut savoir à l'échelle de livres ne
reste plus que 1 % de la végétation de
zone message
donc ce qui fait qu effectivement donc
il ya matière à mettre en place des
actions pour protéger ce milieu qui
devient de plus en plus rares donc qu'on
retrouve comme je le dit alors que tu
mens sur les zones escarpées et
l'objectif c'est de pouvoir donc
préservé donc ce milieu donc à part des
actions donc soit donc la lutte contre
les espèces invasives notamment les
rênes papillon et puis à toutes les
opérations d'entretien de restauration
écologique de plantation qui sont menées
pour renforcer donc les populations donc
d'espèces indigènes donc au niveau du
milieu une protection une valorisation
qui passe d'abord par des chantiers et
c'est l'objet de la visite d'aujourd'hui
sur ce site
l'objectif voir si le travail est bien
effectué et surtout vérifier que
l'espace et protéger et valoriser
on est au domaine fleurier donc un
espace naturel qui relève de la
politique des espaces naturels sensibles
donc là on est dans une zone d'accueil
donc c'est un site qui fait à peu près
une centaine d'états des visites de
terrain qui se font donc avec la brigade
des ems ses hommes participent à
vérifier que les sites sont bien
entretenus mais il veille également
respect des règles qui régissent
l'utilisation des espaces mise à
disposition du public
quand un milieu très très fragile et là
aujourd'hui donc nous sommes venus sur
le site donc en présence de la brigade
et hoeness pour contrôler et donc les
travaux donc qu'ils sont réalisés par
nos gestionnaires
qu'est ce que vous avez vous pu voir
tout à l'heure donc c'est leur
l'entretien donc de la zone d'accueil
non par le g7 qui est le gestionnaire du
site
on est assez remonté donc on peut
dresser un procès verbal
profitant du même petit carnet une
répression rare puisque les familles
réunionnaises ont compris l'importance
de respecter les emplacements qui sont
mis à leur disposition
mais pour que le message passe encore
mieux une sensibilisation est fait
depuis plusieurs années auprès du jeune
public
déjà en fête l'association avec les
enfants depuis scolaire donc du puy 10
12 ans on fait ça on voit une
progression dans
sur l'environnement lorenzo saint
sauveur et les hommes de la brigade
seront ensuite sur un emplacement
particulier qui accueillera bientôt une
expérimentation originale et unique donc
là ce que vous voyez donc c'est une
ainsi donc sur lesquels effectivement
qu'on va mettre en place les ruches donc
il ya deux sites qui ont été définis sur
le domaine fleurier donc il ya un site
en partie rock et puis mais un site ici
et donc ça fait partie effectivement
donc d'une valorisation des espaces
naturels en mettant en place donc des
ruches qui participe aussi d'une
certaine façon donc à la ja la
préservation de la biodiversité donc en
pollinisant les espèces indigènes qui
sont présents donc voilà donc tout tout
c'est peut-être là tout sept enfants
dont coco effectivement aussi à la
préservation et à la préservation de la
biodiversité donc au niveau du guidon en
floride c'est ici à la direction de
l'environnement que lorenzo veille à la
mise en place de ces chantiers en
répartissant mieux ses équipes pour des
interventions sur tout le département
une équipe de six personnes qui
intervient sur l'ensemble de l'île
donc seuls 5000 et a donc une équipe qui
est plutôt sur la façade ouest nord
ouest
et puis l'équipe pour que sur la façade
la façade est que ce fait deux équipes
de trois personnes des milieux naturels
rares mais qui s'ouvre régulièrement
public
ainsi ce sont plus de 800 mille
visiteurs qui viennent profiter chaque
année de ces territoires
prochain rendez vous important avec les
réunionnais il a fait de la nature du
travail de dossiers au rendu sur le
terrain
lorenzo et la brigade des ems marche
plusieurs kilomètres dans l'année dans
cette partie basse du domaine fleurier
se sentir rejoint celui du chemin des
anglais qui mène à la grande chaloupe
des points gps sont nécessaires pour
permettre de bien identifier les espèces
et ainsi mieux les protéger
la prise de points gps donc c'est pour
pouvoir ensuite de reporter sur une
carte et pour lorsqu on reviendra sur le
site par la suite donc à ce moment là
donc on aura un point de repère qui nous
permettra à ce moment là de pouvoir donc
donc voir un petit peu ce qui était ce
qui était répertorié ce qui était notée
donc lors de la visite aujourd'hui
lorenzo saint sauveur et son équipe
veulent continuer à arpenter cette
végétation pour que jamais ne
disparaisse et que chaque réunionnais
puissent continuer à profiter de cette
vue imprenable et de ses forêts
luxuriantes le département oeuvre avec
ses équipes à restaurer et valoriser ce
site avec l'aide des gestionnaires si
nous sommes ici au coeur du parc
cela fait plus d'une vingtaine d'années
que la collectivité en collaboration
avec l'eau nf bate a gardé ses sites en
tact pour que les prochaines générations
puissent profiter pleinement de son
patrimoine végétal et de ses milliers
d'espèces endémiques qui font la
richesse de l'est de la réunion